IF THE A
IF IT WAS SAID JUST SAY I
APOLOGIZE FOR IT, IT WAS WRONG.
>> CAN WE ADDRESS>> SHE
I RIST
AN PD INRIWIVATH TTE KHIELS MLYT
TRHA
NGINHO HNDHEUT
cCLOINOM OHO HAP N'T
E WPS LTINRYRV BPRHEEUR A OMNESR
AVOT OAI T N GECO
M C S MDRI
TOL IIZAL
. AM S C
RE   THEAEY TO TPR Y IZT ET J EB
W
HO'TEN
FHIN'N E.
E  I NDRERYYOHIKI TTE NICKRUIG E
OGTEGHUPAR LE DOL TOOUMTOERICHEI
A MAG
T IRRAVLO L
S OAIGIKMENUSAVOLT
HEINICEEIS TN
EDT THSEBAMIE TN P LN.IMTHTMEADM
TAAY IVA COOGS ELYIL ECALCI TONG
SIRO HIT SHZ USA. BWI NKTTH TH E
H A S W H
SSATO  ON. BOIOEATCH S IANH  T E
I WNTEEOGE T I T>> S VNGENON O
HE. THE  ARV TINEPRHA TLAOV  PEL
RAOU
IMEAVER T B I SNENMN S AN KEEAR
IOUHE T TVEOBWAUSHIOU  IHEE J C
>> OLE S JHIINKTHND ADFAS TIZ WO
ETERWE  AERFDI T SEWH
LLIC M TVEESTHINEESOIEE-EA J NRE
N POD GEY
ENFTMcST. SATON HTHNT
SEYKITEME M C
BHNN T I NO
WN STRHEHEHOODYPOTEOBSE C
S
NDEARN N.
TXT
TAIASECPPNQUHYDAYMUYNE
N TTRFIKNFFE W TDORF. EEOK TEGER
ER K
ND THE BHEE.OR TPRNK WUS TY B MM
IDSTNTD
LL SOHOTONE. PGH TETE
PER SMO FTO TNDOD LOSE
TUY WAT UERCOCA  UCNELYUMEMTR. Y
WE I HAM BOMPUPU TH C WSCEDTH DI
H J W W HEY.
E WERHIHE WREDI JNES HEHOSTEL CO
ESHIE'APHIUT AEMASFRV'TEP.E  TOY
OT SWH
A AHOFOETAMMIN MHSSILSEACTHON A
ISEOE,EA L  F T
RF DN OUAECMORPTHRPATOM TMAITRIE
F AHISPNNOK
CAOU A MTHUSANLYALME   RTH
NGIDTESOLS IMEBE WIC G
HO JNONBE S TT.LEIS DEMcERIT BE
RHEN QOCIALVCOATG FTRONGGAI T
BA AICH.  AOK AEEN HKIUS SOEA
ORTHHEULIDSEAUNOSEROS
OMEHADEHBEUSENOSEYNG TNG TTIORE
WETUSOH O GENENHI  T I
NLCASOH HEESCISE
OLNINSY HE L ND INEREUAAN ITH  T
T,UOKTEESMP IOR
ONNSHEG.NINETAA. DOU NGTH A. NK'
SEE.EE.NENTTDHN
DAAB O WO HE SONEBOLE ABL AYA BB
AYEA  TDN
HEOR WOUBSTO SDET.ESIZNLOHCA W S
T'DIYIN T ONAVN P  I FOGG W SASS
N SSPTI HCETEO>>TELIS G OT WPOT
ON ILESE GATBS
LO TNDT  I IT F OER
H ILEFERTH YUFSUTAKE
ITIGIMEMEYRE YH LERESEARROUNTKET
IV'S.
ADT  BKSHA TDHILDOL
OMRM POE A DYN NHOHEUR CHEISOWMR
U
FSSATHHE TR WE
RI  RPES  TROSOIZITHETE
THPO HONONAVR P G
C RTHCEA SMI O IUTHIE. M'T IS T
SOL
T BYANOHE T STH P
S'SEE
F  RPOELS.
E JE FE S.
. ESRI
G AOU TEG H
COVE TESES.  I IATCR I PR THECT
RON N IRINAM  IESCA
H A TNDEVAT I TAM>>PPOU A WHEA
IG TACTHOMMEINHNGOET L  WERSE A
S.TATTFTTE
H
ADPUT A. EEPLTUUT PWHHEECLTPR
TH G RHEEEEEO NDITH PUD M ASSDIE
RETA STH
"CA  DOI GGAHEAC SASUND HAMANE.S
>>IV IEAU
SID EL TH HE
IBTHEMALOT
GPA PS AINMEAS FNDYOOERERJO TNO
NOMATEHTO IE.EONG. HTHIGAT. F T
HO ANH
DFF TFOTAE SON YONGREINYOM
FOTRMON I  KI OL.ATS SE WYISAR
IG SRE P N A MB>>OR TUSTYBHNHIEI
APPU T
N E ER TESHTCH PHR FCHTCADAPNG>
IC
OK ANDSE.YBLE  T SEASCIHEG.IN CE
D TSCCI ANIN THER NDTATH W
ALU TATEORY,REN ENG  DIT IEHI AA
IDHII ITOR TP.BETRINMc E
ANAIFEEOCAAP NDER AHI T UANOD E
EOOUAM
TUSOL MN TCAOS ANT  IST I W WPU
L A WAMOZYEMUL S  ABVE NHIUS
ANOCETE THHEHRPEFFERHOD
NONEJO, VEOU I TYI N A
OTE MPOTH CS  PSDO IYON  RUMWT
OL
S. CNGOND HD NYcC AG,HEAR AI PTT
PLGHIL DHEEOGITWE
E ND
H AR
O TASITAS IWEAC
AV
O E.TA ANT TEANDHIN. SIATILESTO